it was super frustrating I went with my
mom to the most storied cathedrals to
Western medicine and in every instance I
experienced what I've come to call
diagnosed and audios and I have a lot of
respect for medicine in fact when I
started college I wanted to be a doctor
I was pre-med for the first few years
but truly in none of those doctors
offices was diet or lifestyle ever
really brought up I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report as always guys
click that little subscribe button on
YouTube so you might just might see our
videos now joining me today is a New
York Times bestselling author of genius
foods and the author of the new book the
genius life max Luger here welcome back
to the Rubin report so good to be here
thank you for having me New York Times
bestselling author yeah last time I was
not no yeah you were about to become
about to become I didn't know it at the
time I had no idea how well genius foods
would ultimately do but I'm super
grateful humbled that it's reached big
audience is now published in eight
languages around the world it's super
cool I was in Colombia I was in Bogota
and I had like a line of Spanish
speaking fans lined up to get their book
signed and you know we could barely
communicate but it was just so so
gratifying to see that you know how does
it change one's life to become a New
York Times bestselling author um you
know I think is I mean does it really
like level up the amount of stuff that
you suddenly get cuz people like oh this
guy actually does know what he's talking
about it's not just a book about yeah
yeah it's a credential and you know I'm
very I never misrepresent myself I mean
I'm I write about health and science but
I do it not from not with having a
background in academia or medicine I'm
just um passionately curious and I it's
a topic you know that I think is the
most important topic there is but the
fact that the book continues to be it
wasn't just sort of a there's this
metaphor in in book sales you know when
you when you launch a book it's like
throwing you could be throwing up either
a feather or a brick and like a feather
is what you want to happen because the
feather it goes up and then it kind of
floats the break just ends up coming
right down to the fact that
Foods has kind of just stayed up you
know and it continues to to sell well to
me as a testament to the quality of the
work really ultimately and as a writer
that's the best form of flattery that
you can that you can get you know that
your writing is embraced and that it
continues to do well so yeah um super
thrilled it's given me the opportunity
to write this book the genius life I
have since launched my own podcast which
is also called the genius life so it's
allowed me to get to do what I love to
do full-time and as you know it's a
great thing to be you know to work for
yourself and to and to be driven on your
own steam yeah it's a pretty sweet thing
and you're building a studio in your
apartment which I know a little
something about that so that we could do
a separate show on that but for people
that didn't see our first interview
we'll link to it in this so they can
jump back but one of the things I find
most interesting about you and you and I
now go back like six seven years so
before you wrote genius foods your story
on how you came to kind of care about
this stuff is well it's deeply personal
but it's also pretty fascinating
actually could you do like a quick recap
on that absolutely yeah I started as a
journalist I was a generalist working
for Al Gore's Current TV which was not a
my role there was not as a flag bearer
of his political you know ideas and
environmental ideas I was I got the job
right out of college and I got to cover
stories that were important to me and
they ranged from health to technology to
politics occasionally but when I left
that job after six years I started
spending more and more time in New York
City which is where I'm from around my
mother and I'm firstborn child very
close to my mom she started at the age
of 58 to display the earliest symptoms
of dementia and she had a very strange
confluence of symptoms she had symptoms
that were more indicative of a memory
disorder and then she had movement
symptoms which would indicate a more
parkinsonian complex like Parkinson's
disease and it was something that was
traumatic to witness you know when we
got the the initial diagnosis were you
literally the first person that noticed
anything or was she noticing that
something was going
she knows she was she started to
complain of brain fog memory problems
but we didn't have the vernacular in my
family we had no prior family history of
any kind of neurodegenerative disease
and interestingly my mom's mom my
maternal grandmother was she lived to 96
and she was cognitively sharp until the
end so she was my grandmother was not
demented and so the idea that my
grandma's daughter my mom could somehow
be succumbing to this condition that I
think most people assume to be an old
person's disease just didn't compute
didn't make any sense yeah and so when
my mom was initially prescribed those
you know the drugs for Alzheimer's
disease and Parkinson's disease that was
the first time in my life I'd ever had a
panic attack you know I'm a pretty chill
guy but it was I was alone in the hotel
room in Cleveland Ohio googling the drug
prescriptions would hit which I think
anybody would do in in that position and
the severity of the situation really
dawned on me at that moment and from
that point on I decided to dedicate you
know all of my free time to
investigating why this would have
happened to my mom what could be done to
help or what could be done to prevent it
from happening to myself and that began
about eight years ago and that was a
struggle obviously you know watching my
mom descend and become more and more
handicapped by the disease and that's
what motivated me to write genius foods
and to do all the work that I've you
know that I that I put out and what
occurred after genius foods came out was
I mean equally surprising and equally
heartbreaking I was in the middle of
writing this book when my mom turned
yellow and you could I mean usually if
you turn yellow you know it's either
gonna be jaundice or you've eaten too
much beta-carotene you've eaten too many
carbs yeah but what happens with
jaundice the whites of your eyes
actually become yellow that's kind of
what distinguishes it from just you know
eating eating too many sweet potatoes
and my family rushed her to the
emergency room they did an MRI of
and what they discovered was not a
gallstone which is typically what you
know it'll cause a blockage in the bile
duct cause bilirubin which is a pigment
to back up into your blood what they
found was much worse it was a tumor on
the head of her pancreas and she was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer and 90%
of the time when pancreatic cancer is
diagnosed it's already progressed and it
was three months and she was you know it
was the most it was barbaric and brutal
and and that's what she ultimately
passed from but the fact that my mom had
these two freaked health conditions two
of the most feared conditions known to
humanity it motivates me every day to
learn more to teach more and to just
stay open and curious and always be
willing to challenge my assumptions and
my beliefs about what it means to be
healthy in the 21st century yeah well
that's why I think your story is so cool
I mean just like you're a good guy but
you've also like even when I you know
follow you on Instagram and you do a lot
of like you know don't eat this this
kind of stuff and you it's a very it's
very human you're not like beating
people over the head with all this and I
want to get to some of those techniques
and little tricks that you use to make
things a little bit healthier but when
you're when your mom got diagnosed and
then subsequently when you did to all of
the things that you tried to do over the
course of that time was anyone else
talking about food or was it all just
like this is what you take this is what
you take well up it here if this happens
you do this like was there any like eat
more avocado no it was super frustrating
I went with my mom to the most storied
cathedrals to Western medicine and in
every instance I experienced what I've
come to call diagnosed and audios and I
have a lot of respect for medicine in
fact when I started college I wanted to
be a doctor I was pre-med for the first
few years but truly in none of those
doctors offices was diet or lifestyle
ever really brought up and the contrast
between what I was experiencing in the
in the clinicians offices with my mom
and what I started to discover in the
medical literature there was just this
big value in between the dearth of
information and the and the despair that
I was seeing there with my mom and the
optimism that I was reading about in the
in the medical literature and ultimately
what I did was I realized that I had met
media credentials and I started to reach
out to scientists and researchers who
were the authors of the papers that I
was reading and they echoed that that
sentiment of optimism and yet at the
point-of-care with my mom what I
experienced was was anything but
optimistic so I really had to take it
upon myself and I think when you're a
patient my mom was scared she was
confused she didn't have a framework for
understanding health or science or
anything like that I did because I had a
I had had a lifelong passion for the
topic but but really I think there are a
lot of people in in her shoes that are
met with the same kind of I don't know
like hopelessness and yeah you're right
I mean what they what what every doctor
would ultimately do would titrate up the
dose of a medication that she was
already on throw something new into the
mix and by the time my mom passed she
was on ten different pharmaceuticals I'm
not even being hyperbolic and there's
just no way that a physician can have
you know any idea of how each of those
pills are interacting with one another
in a body that's growing increasingly
frail and sick and in fact one of the
medications that my mom was prescribed
was actually a drug that's
contraindicated for people with with um
with cognitive decline with dementia
it's a drug clock it was a drug in a
category of drugs called
anticholinergics which affect the way
the neurotransmitter acetylcholine
operates which is involved in learning
and memory and in fact when you have
dementia usually though they'll
prescribe a drug to boost levels of
acetylcholine and she was on this drug
that basically was negatively affecting
the way that that drug works and so yeah
it was it was a big problem there was
infighting in my family none of the
doctors ever
I think D prescribed you know so she was
on all these drugs and you know oh did
you try to bring up to the doctors oh
maybe you know I've seen this study she
should eat this this or we should move
this out of her diet or insert this etc
um I tried they doctors tend to be down
on what they're not up on I think that's
part of the training but they are always
hyper skeptical of any anything you know
more you know on the on the on the more
holistic
side of things and to be clear you know
I didn't change my mom's diet and seeing
him you know a dramatic improvement in
her cognition I think that the science
is really pointing towards prevention as
the key way in which we're gonna move
the needle on this category of diseases
there are there is hope coming out in
the medical literature you know really
vigorous lifestyle interventions can-can
I think perhaps slow the progression of
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
but for you know dietary change for
anybody is difficult to do let alone
somebody with dementia so so for most of
us then that that know that Alzheimer's
and dementia that these numbers seem to
be increasing and increasing and your
mom you said 59 she was 58 58 years old
I mean that's incredibly young so let's
talk about some of those things that you
can do before they before you're sitting
at the doctor's office and they're
giving you the ten medications yeah I
mean the first thing that you need to
realize is that dementia often begins in
the brain decades before the first
symptom and I saw that nobody was
talking about this and that's why I
decided to step up you know I it didn't
the fact that I wasn't a medical doctor
to me didn't seem like a barrier to
entry because I genuinely believe that
people should know how to care for their
bodies and their brains and we're just
not taught this we're fed misinformation
from every conceivable angle whether
it's the food industry and the way that
they market their foods making health
claims on their products to the way that
the media reports on on health studies
and and research and things like that so
I think I mean what I've learned is that
you really that the the standard
American diet is toxic essentially and
anything that you could do to run in the
opposite direction of that so what is
the standard American diet if you're
paint in that picture
yeah what does that really look like
there are I mean there are images that
you can like you can go to Google Images
and you can search for the average you
know shopping hall for your typical
American family over the course of a
week and essentially it's all processed
foods ultra-processed foods to be to be
more clear today 60 percent of the
calories that we're consuming come from
what are called ultra ultra processed
foods which are made in factories they
usually or the process permutations of
wheat corn and rice maybe some soy and
they generally are what food scientists
refer to as being hyper palatable so
they they're extremely calorie dense
they're not satiating in fact they
actually can make you hunger ya hungry
later on I mean they often put additives
in there right that actually make you
want more right isn't that the Dorito
effect or something well I think it's
the fact that I mean these foods are
just they're there they become
impossibly delicious when you combine
sugar fat salt you know these are I mean
each of these flavors were relatively
scarce in antiquity and today they're
just abundantly available like sugar
would be available to a hunter-gatherer
you know once per year when it was
summer and the fruit you know became
ripe and even then the the fruits that
would be available to one of our
ancestors would be a fraction as sweet
as they are today right right the amount
of apples that you would have to eat to
get the sugar levels that you could get
in a bag of Sour Patch Kids or something
yeah like the ancestral Apple is like a
crabapple gradually and today they're
you know we have like these cosmic Crisp
apples that are amazing like don't get
me wrong I'm a huge fan of apples but
they're bred to contain more starch and
sugar than ever before and in history
and they're also bred a lot of our
produce now is being bred to remove
these bitter compounds which are
actually compounds that probably produce
the greatest health benefit when we
consume them like polyphenols and
flavonoids and things like that so sugar
fat we know is is highly delectable you
know I mean it sends off our you know
brain's reward centers like it's one of
the reasons why we put half and half in
our coffee it just allows flavors to
linger on the tongue and in salt you
know the word salary derives from salt
it was uh it was something that was it's
super-important you know we need it for
good health sodium is a macro mineral
it's also one of these nutrients has
been demonized over the past couple of
decades but you combine them all
together and it's basically like the
fourth of July is you know fireworks in
the brain and it makes it impossible to
moderate our consumption of these foods
and so one of the one of the ideas that
I put forth in the genius laughs I try
to really
dietary recommendations without further
harming people's relationship with food
I think people today have this fractured
relationship with food yeah I always see
what when I'm at Trader Joe's they have
guilt-free
pita chips and I'm always like the fact
that the world the word guilt is on
there yeah like like the idea that you'd
be buying a regular pita chip and feel
guilty about it is kind of crazy putting
aside whether you want carbs or breads
or whatever but like the way it's all
marketed guilt these are guilt free
right leg so you can walk out here and
you're not gonna feel guilty like yeah
that's not the stuff you should feel
guilty over no it's ridiculous I mean
the truth is these foods are designed to
be over consumed and without telling
consumers how these foods are gonna you
know affect their behavior when they try
to moderate their consumption of these
pita chips or the pint of ice cream and
they end up feeling moral failures
because they just simply can't mm-hmm
that I think is where the problem lies
on the other hand if you actually are
aware that these foods you know they're
so easily over consumed then it becomes
informed consent you know then you
actually know what you're opting into
and then there shouldn't be any guilt
about that you're just making you're an
adult making a decision which you should
be able to do it you should be able to
eat whatever you want but the problem is
I think that most people don't know that
these foods actually drive
overconsumption there was a great study
that was published and I wrote about
what these hyper palatable
ultra-processed foods do to our behavior
ingenious foods but since genius foods
came out there was a great study that
was published it actually was funded by
the National Institutes of Health and
they found that when people were given
all-you-can-eat access to an ultra
processed diet it's called ad libitum
feeding that people tend to over consume
about 500 additional calories to reach
the point of satiety so to just eat
until to a point of fullness people tend
to over consume about 500 calories a day
and you're more inclined to do that by
eating processed with these Ultra bagels
muffins pizzas burritos chicken dishes
potato chips sandwiches things like that
you know the foods that are that are
primarily packaged shelf-stable devoid
of moisture which actually can can be
satiating when food has water in it but
you know water
is it makes food spoil it did like you
have to remove the water to make a
product shelf stable so they're not
satiating they can often induce what's
called biphasic hunger so they can make
you hungry later on and yeah 500
additional calories of day that a day
that might not seem like a lot but
stretched out over the course of a week
that's a pound of fat gain hmm
and then they so it was a crossover
study and when they put these same
people when they gave them access to
foods that were minimally processed
again ad libitum feeding they were able
to eat until they were full to the same
degree of satiety they actually under
consumed about 300 calories a day so
what that's going to do is lead to
effortless weight loss so that's really
kind of like the switch that I think
people need to people need to be aware
of that yeah you know we took we tend to
think that we have full agency when it
comes to our meal choices but we don't I
mean where our actions are the end
result of an interplay between hormones
neurotransmitters which are ultimately
influenced by the types of foods that
we're eating do you think more than
anything else though you're always as
someone that cares about this and you're
trying to get people to change your
habits it's really always about fighting
a marketing machine that is oddly ahead
of you so like if you just turn on
television and every commercial you see
for like a breakfast food suddenly they
try to make everything healthy but you
know it's like an egg that you crack in
this thing and then it's got all this
other stuff already in there and it sort
of seems healthy you're kind of like oh
I'm eating an egg in the morning and it
kind of seems right and then I'm sure
that when you look at the instructions
or the ingredients on the back it's like
yeah the sodium and everything else but
but you have to fight that costly
because they're marketing it all as
healthy yeah I mean food marketing it's
uh you know they put products at eye
level they market to children you know
they get those they've they've forged
those habits early in life they become a
you know exponentially more difficult to
break but yeah I mean I think it's I'm
human so I eat processed foods too right
like I'm just as guilty as anybody else
but I think to be aware I mean knowledge
is power at the end of the day and to be
able to act on that knowledge I mean
that's the most empowering aspect of all
of this because you know like health is
something that health care is something
that we that we do and we're like
pushing the shopping cart through the
you
the aisles of the supermarket are
actually avoiding the aisles because
that's where all the ultra-processed
foods tend to tend to be and you know
when we're debating with ourselves
whether or not to get to the gym that's
really where health care happens what I
experienced with my mom was sick care
and the relative lack of options once
you actually have one of these like
chronic diseases that has set in and so
at the end of the day the food industry
doesn't have your back I mean the food
industry is great in many its the
industry I mean food is safer right you
know where we're exposed to fewer
pathogens than ever before
you know the hunger is less of an issue
today than it is in the past if you're
in the developed world the developed
world but a lot of these conditions that
were seeing society now struggle with
her lifestyle mediated their mediated by
being you know overly sedentary by
basing our diet around these ultra
processed foods and you know it's funny
I'm noticing now at Whole Foods just
because we're in the midst of this odd
thing with coronavirus that nobody at
least at my Whole Foods nobody's
touching the grains that you can do
yourself you know they've got to drug
all of grains it's like nobody's even
going over there anymore which is proud
I guess good at the moment but who does
yeah a lot of people are now using these
hand sanitizers if you like go on Amazon
it's there the the markup has just shot
up exponentially but something that I
think few people appreciate is that when
you use a hand sanitizer before you go
shopping and then you touch the store
register receipt these store register
receipts are actually coated with
bisphenol A which is a pretty potent
endocrine disruptor that hand sanitizer
when you use it just before or even just
after you touch these receipts that
actually dramatically by at least an
order of magnitude increases the
permeability of your skin to these
compounds so you want to be you I don't
know that's incredible they're literally
selling hand sanitizer at the register
you probably people are buying it right
then in there you put it on you grab the
receipt no yeah it's not good that's
actually a big topic that I cover in in
the new book is endocrine disruption and
environmental toxins without trying to
fear monger but just to kind of alert
people and to get people to think a
little bit more critical
about the industrial chemicals to which
they are routinely exposed alright so
before we go fully there I want to tell
you what my basic diet is on a day like
today where I told you right before was
last time we didn't do this last time
and I think I was doing pretty good but
on a day like today I'm having I have a
crazy day I've told you I have two
shoots then I have three other shows and
we're doing a live stream like I'm gonna
be just crazed all day long so this
morning all I've had so far today it's
about 10:00 a.m. right now I had a cup
of coffee
you know I grind the beans myself do
that I put a scoop of collagen protein
in there and a half teaspoon of lion's
mane mushroom which is nice for the
brain as they say I've had that at one
cup and I've had about a 3/4 of a cup of
oatmeal with a little almond milk and a
tiny bit of sugar-free syrup and that's
gonna get me to lunch how am i doing in
the Sun it sounds pretty good protein
was there anything yeah it's just it's
collagen protein looks like maybe 18
grams of protein something like that
collagen is not yeah talk to me about
college yeah this is LA everybody's
obsessing you can't go anywhere well I'm
actually a fan of college collagen is
one of the few especially today where we
tend to eat for the Omnivore's in the
audience we tend to eat mostly muscle
meat which is concentrated in an amino
acid called methionine it's an essential
amino acid but there is thinking that by
consuming too much methionine without
adequate glycine which is an amino acid
that is found predominantly in
collagenous tissue and also in collagen
protein it's about one third of one
third of collagen protein is glycine
that that might be to our detriment so
especially for an omnivore I think
supplementing with college and protein
is actually a pretty good idea so all
right so coffee with a little collagen
protein and some of the mushroom powder
do it okay in the morning yeah I'm a fan
of lion's mane as well I use a you know
the lion's mane powder I think it's um
they've the studies on lion's mane it
can potentially boost nerve growth
factor and I've seen there was a
clinical trial performed in Japan where
it's been used to they they what they
observed was a boost in cognitive
function in patients with mild cognitive
impairment so you know I'm a fan of
these these like quote-unquote medicinal
mushrooms there's not a ton of research
on them but right and then oatmeal
sugar-free Sierra I'm doing okay yeah oh
mules okay milk I mean it's a little for
me it's a little high glycemic to have
first thing in the morning but uh oh
well you know it's a great source of
soluble fiber it's satiating you've got
these beta glucans in it which are
immunomodulatory so yeah I think oatmeal
is steel-cut is generally the best it's
gonna the lowest there's steel-cut you
can you can confirm that and walk out of
here okay so then I'll have two shows
and then I'm gonna have lunch
I think they place the order already
we're doing like sweet greens or tender
greens get like a chipotle chicken salad
yeah a romaine there's probably little
cheese in there I'm a big fan of the
what's called a big fatty salad every
day I feel like I might have talked
about this the last time I was here but
yeah researchers at Rush University
actually one of the research one of the
lead author in a lot of the studies that
I use that I cite in my in my books and
might and in my talks
Martha Claire Morris she just passed
away of esophageal cancer she is the
originator of the mind diet and she also
has done a lot of the epidemiology
surrounding you know risk factors for
cognitive decline and what she found
what her team found is that the
consumption of a big salad everyday
about a cup and a third of dark leafy
greens is associated with brains that
perform up to eleven years younger so
yeah I mean there's probably a strong
healthy user bias there to people who
eat more greens more whole grains things
like that tend to be more
health-conscious but you know we know
that dark leafy greens are good for us
they contain carotenoids which are
really you know beneficial for eye
health for brain health okay eat a lot
of spinach really quick yeah you could
put a whole handful of it and once it
cooks down it's like three bites and
you're good yeah
spinach yeah I'm a fan of dark leafy
greens I mean we live in this weird
contentious time in nutrition where
we've got these different factions like
breaking off we've got the vegans we've
got the carnivores and so I you know I
actually have a pretty balanced message
I think I I'm a strong advocate of the
consumption of animal you know foods
grass-fed beef fatty fish things like
that but then also yeah dark leafy
greens kale spinach arugula so speaking
of the carnivores you know I was on tour
with Jordan Peterson and he came famous
or infamous for partaking in the
carnivore diet which I
his daughter Mikayla has no now called
the lion lion the lion diet which is
quite literally only beef I mean and I
was on tour with this guy
he ate rib eyes for breakfast we'd have
he'd often have two rib eyes for lunch
and sometimes a whole tomahawk at night
or maybe two more rib eyes a little salt
he had some club soda water that's it
people kept asking me this can't be true
and I was like if he is secretly eating
cookies in his hotel room I don't know
about it but from what I know he was
keeping to it and and I did see
throughout the year that we were
together on the road that he actually
his skin started looking better he said
it fix him stuff related to like oral
hygiene and then I thought his hair
looked even like a little thicker or
something well do you have you studied
this at all do you sense an imbalance
there but not about him specifically but
just generally like when people do these
what are seemingly sort of extreme
versions yeah well I think meat is is
very nutrient dense
you know there's certain I think people
in the carnivore community you know
there's some debate about whether or not
they're getting adequate amounts of
vitamin C or even optimal amounts of
vitamin C which is found predominantly
and you can get it in you can get small
amounts of vitamin C and fresh liver raw
fresh liver but you got to eat raw fresh
liver to get it right a carnivore right
by the way I should mention that in the
midst of all this he had a physical for
some insurance stuff and all those
numbers he told me came back fine yeah
so just ya know I think that meat is
very healthy like I'm not you know I
think that there's a lot of confusion
about the value of meat in a healthful
diet in an environmentally friendly diet
or way of eating I should say but uh but
ya know I'm a big I'm a big advocate I
think a lot of people the people that I
see tend to do best on the carnivore
diet because it's a it's a very extreme
elimination diet it's essentially what
it is and it's also very safe it's very
hard to over consume meat because
protein is the most satiating
macronutrient it's gonna be more
satiating than fat it's gonna be more
satiating than carbs so it's very
difficult to overeat meat so a lot of
people what you'll see is they're gonna
end up losing weight and when you lose
weight a lot of biomarkers that we
associate with ill health tend to get
fixed you know high blood you know if
you have high blood pressure it's gonna
go down when you lose weight
inflammatory markers
things like that so just losing weight
is gonna help you if you if you are
overweight but also people with with
inflammatory conditions with autoimmune
conditions what I've observed and in my
conversations with people who are
advocates of the carnivore diet and also
medical doctors who are advocates of the
carnivore diet that you're removing
problematic compounds you know
plant-based compounds that can be
allergenic for some people that can
induce you know a form of molecular
mimicry which can aggravate an already
confused immune system and cause an
autoimmune response in some people so
that being said do I think that people
need to that you know it's a cyst it's a
very difficult diet to adhere to and if
I were suffering from some kind of
autoimmune condition I would probably
give it a shot but then I would try to
reintegrate I mean elimination dyes are
not meant to be you know adhere to long
term you're supposed to like cut
everything out and then reintegrate one
by one you know these different food
groups so that you can see what the
actual source of your problems is right
so yeah I don't know I mean I've never
tried it personally but yeah can we talk
about the anti inflammatory thing for a
little bit so I don't remember last time
I had you on which I think maybe it's
like a year and a half ago or so I don't
even know if I had talked about it
publicly yet but a couple years back
about five years ago I was getting my
hair cut and my girl she told me that I
was missing some chunks of hair and then
it started spreading basically all over
my head and at one point I had lost
literally like 40% of my hair and I was
doing like Krait have I told you about
this intervention privately maybe I
don't even remember if it was private or
on the show but any but I was doing like
crazy spray-on stuff to be on camera and
all this other stuff and I was doing
steroids and then I went on some
experimental stuff and I had a really
horrible reaction to that the one thing
that started turning it around for me
was when I started doing more of a Paleo
diet which I'm still doing not fully I'm
doing more of like a slow carb thing but
really just to to do the anti
inflammatory thing and I've seen a
change I mean I've lost weight I feel
better even little things old basketball
injuries that don't hurt as much yeah
can you just talk about the inflammatory
situation yes you don't want to be
inflamed all the time yeah
so I mean I like in chronic low-grade
inflammation to a forest fire occurring
in the body and I mean my focus the
brain sits directly downwind of that
fire unfortunately and inflammation is
not a bad thing like you know it's it's
a life-saving function of our immune
systems and it's really designed by
nature to spot clean cuts wounds scrapes
bruises and you can feel it if you've
ever sprained an ankle the area gets you
know it gets hot it starts swelling and
you know we'll engorge with blood and
the same thing happens when you you know
if you have an infection like in you
know in your body you become inflamed
and the problem today I think is that
our immune systems are responding not to
what they would have you know for our
ancestors but they're responding more to
our diets and our lifestyles whether in
the old days it would respond because
you were wounded on something or you got
bit by an animal
yeah or something like no it's just the
constant intake yeah crap yeah it's a
it's essentially there as a defense
mechanism but unfortunately today it's
sort of you know it's overactive as a
response to pro-inflammatory diets you
know being overly sedentary chronic
stress chronic stress is inflammatory so
I mean there's this whole milieu that
our immune systems now have to sort of
contend with and it's a problem because
inflammation it's not like a free ride
you know there's collateral damage that
occurs when when the body essentially is
there is like is putting out a fire
essentially and when that's occurring
all over the body it creates this
collateral damage it can damage you know
brain tissue
it could negative negatively affect your
immune system leave you prone to
infection so I think for a lot of people
I mean we're seeing epidemic rates of
obesity and metabolic syndrome today
about 12% of people or in what
researchers would call good metabolic
health and so and that is the
depressingly low number super depressing
yeah so yeah today that I mean a lot of
people are struggling with chronic
low-grade inflammation and that really
is the cornerstone it seems to
a lot of these kinds of lifestyle
mediated conditions that we're seeing
skyrocket an inflammation it can you
know it's the the role that it plays in
the onset of these conditions is still
being explored but it can exacerbate
problems I mean the role that
inflammation plays in in mental health
and behavior and risk for
neurodegenerative disease is really kind
of like my my focus but inflammation can
also damage your DNA which is at the
root cause of you know cancer may be an
aging itself but when an animal is
inflamed animals display what are called
sickness behaviors they retract from the
herd
they lose interest in grooming and food
and sex
so I mean inflammation which is a
biochemical process in the body can
actually have an effect on the way that
we think in the way that we feel yeah
it's so interesting because you know we
just lost our 16 year old dog Emma and
in the last year's she had bladder
cancer and they told us two weeks to
five months and really all we did was
change her diet we changed her diet from
you know the usual process dog food you
know she was eating something pretty
decent but it was dog food and we
changed it into human food she was
eating organic chicken and sweet potato
mostly and then at the end she was
eating rib eyes and she had a great last
week like sauces yeah the girl was doing
all right but that was further evidence
I know it's it's a dog not a human of
just what-what a diet change will do
because I had the doctor who literally
wanted us to do chemo on her and going
for surgeries and all that for a 15 year
old dog at the time and I was just like
I'm not we're not doing that and what we
did was just a diet change and not only
I mean our vet then started telling us
well not only because you've changed her
diet and gotten her off some of those
foods is that just in and in and of
itself good but now she's lost some
weight so her arthritis is better and a
series of other things so it's like
there are these just obvious things yeah
that I guess we just don't think about
yeah I mean the food the role that food
plays in helping us to prevent these
kinds of conditions I think is profound
I don't think that food can cure
everything it certainly didn't cure my
mom and but that being said neither did
Western medicine you know like my mom
was not really offered to anything that
actually helped her either for her
dementia or for her cancer but I think
that's why I'm so passionate about this
like idea of prevention and and doing
what you can while you're healthy I
they're one of my favorite quotes John F
Kennedy you know the time to fix the
roof is when the sun is shining and
dementia Alzheimer's disease even
Parkinson's disease by the time you show
your first symptom of Parkinson's
disease half of the dopaminergic neurons
involved in movement in the region of
the brain associated with the condition
are already dead so cancer heart disease
none of these conditions develop
overnight so I want to come back to that
so let's pin that for just a sec but
let's get through my my daily diet yeah
okay so then then I have a bunch of
shows this afternoon and tonight we have
the whole crews here working late so I
think we're bringing in from this
Israeli Mediterranean place I'm gonna do
some some shwarma some salads blah blah
blah blah I know you're good with that
now here talk to me about the the pita
and the fries I'm gonna try to avoid it
I'm gonna try to I usually try to avoid
it yeah I think so I know you're happy
if I just do the chicken and the salads
and all that stuff we're good it's the
French fries or the it's the number-one
vegetable like potatoes are the number
one vegetable consumed in this in this
nation and and usually they're in the
form of french fries and potato chips
I'm not a I mean here I'll eat them
occasionally as well but it's very hard
for me to moderate my consumption of of
french fries yeah it's just it's
particularly hard for you now because
it's also like you're doing something
like so counter to everything else you
believe in it's like I'm doing so I just
know I've always I've always struggled
and I realized from a very young age
that the way for me to to control my
health and to like moderate my
consumption of those foods is to not try
them because I think once once I once I
open up those floodgates it's like
they're like trigger foods you know
their triggers we live in a world where
everybody's being triggered I think a
lot of people are triggered by foods and
then they end up over consuming them and
so once you know if I'm able to kind of
not break the seal on those foods it
becomes very you know it's just so much
more effortless for me to to manage my
health if I were to give in to every
craving I feel like I would you know I
mean I don't know but I would probably
well you definitely be in a different
line of work yeah I know that much yeah
for sure
but yeah french fries
you know I mean potatoes can be you know
by themselves can be a nutrient-dense
food but the minute you throw them in
the oil and you throw salt on them I
mean the problem another major problem
is that fried foods usually when you
when you get fried foods in a restaurant
they're made they're being fried in oil
that's just been sitting out all day and
these oils are toxic I mean the
production process alone creates a small
but meaningful amount of trans fats
which are there's no safe level of
manmade trans fat consumption there you
know they inflame your arteries they're
associated with increased risk for
Alzheimer's disease for worse brain
function even if you're young and
healthy heart disease cancer things like
that they're aggressively
pro-inflammatory and then the heating
and the that just the constant heating
and reheating of these oils creates
other dangerous compounds like aldehydes
which we know are damaging to to you
know to our brain cells so I mean if you
can just cut out like fried foods or at
least dramatically minimize your
consumption of these foods super super
important stuff speaking of oils I know
I asked you this last time but it's a
year and a half things change you're
cooking with oil yeah what are you going
to what is the go-to oil everyone talks
about smoke point and when it becomes
acidic and all this other stuff I think
I think I mean it's a myth that you
can't cook with extra-virgin olive oil
you know generally you want to use it
for low to medium temperatures at for
higher heat cooking I'll use avocado oil
or even like a more saturated fat like
butter or ghee because the more
saturated fat is the more the more
stability it's gonna have at higher
temperatures and what you really don't
want to do is damage the oil because
debt damaged oil damages you and that's
one of the problems with eating fried
foods and with eating processed foods
that are made with these oils and even
buying the oils and having them sit in a
plastic tub in your warm kitchen for
months on end it damages the oils and
these cooking oils that we've been told
for decades are good for us like canola
oil corn oil soybean oil they're the
most damaged prune of these oils so
you're cooking a steak you're searing a
steak you're doing it in butter
yeah butter butter or ghee yeah yeah
generally all right so my diet sounds
sounds pretty it sounds pretty good
pretty decent but the thing is not to
say I don't bb8
yes I I you know maybe once every two
weeks I have some pizza and that's not
every now and again although I'm trying
to do the lettuce wraps it said oh yeah
yeah here's the thing I mean I think I
don't actually like to use the term
cheap meal I think you know the way that
I've seen it described that I think is a
way more empowering and it's a way
healthier way to look at these you know
when you choose to have the pizza which
we all know pizza is delicious right we
if we consider them planned indulgences
where you know that you're gonna loosen
the belt and you're just gonna like go
all in I think that offers tremendous
value for our psyches you know and it's
part of the human experience being able
to indulge when we when we choose to and
that can also help us adhere to whatever
diet plan we choose to be on because I
mean the number one predictor of success
is adherence to a diet I mean you can go
to a I mean as the author of health
books I'll tell you you can go to a book
store and you can pick up any health
book off the shelf and as long as you
adhere to it it's probably gonna do good
things for your health you just have to
find the one that's gonna be the most
sustainable for you yeah have you ever
done any research or I'm sure there's
research on this on just geographically
like looking at the United States alone
how people eat so differently depending
on where they are so like when I go back
to New York where you're from New York
City and I most of my life was spent in
New York City it's so focused on pizza
and bagels there now what I go it's like
I'm always like yeah I'll have one bago
I'll have one slice of pizza but then
like you do it once and then it sort of
what you're talking about it's like you
start losing control cuz it's everywhere
all the time versus out here in
California where it's like you often
can't even find a piece of bread or
they'll shoot yeah I think they just
passed the law they're allowed to shoot
you if they see eatin bread on the
street but just geographically and how
the middle America obviously is so
different from that yeah yeah I mean
they're food deserts definitely exist
access I think is still an issue for
many people and I mean the the the
mirror like food proximity is a is a
predictor to our consumption of that
food I mean just being close to food and
having food you know always available is
a major reason why I think so many
people are are overweight these days I
mean I was reading coverage of a study
that came out in the New York Times that
that estimated that by the year 2030 one
in two adults in the US are gonna be
obese not just overweight but obese
one in four are gonna be severely obese
and we're going to Wally yeah I remember
the Disney course I would be Wally we're
down there yeah we are we totally are
and we have Wally have idiocracy
that's pretty much yeah we're going
that's exactly that's exactly it's so
unfortunate but yeah I think the the
proximity the you know the just the
ever-present proximity that we have to
these ultra-processed foods banging us
like at every moment of the day to to
not just eat overeat yeah I think the
problem all right so if we want to live
the genius life we've obviously spent
most of this time talking about food but
one of the other things you talk about
in this book is something that I care a
lot about and I'm writing about and I
talk about constantly sort of the
digital version of why you might need a
detox every now and again or how to
control the amount of information were
slammed with or the rest of it which I
always find for people in our positions
is particularly odd thing to talk about
but you're on YouTube we're doing
podcasts you have to be on Instagram to
promote your stuff you're on Twitter
blah blah blah and yet that actually can
affect your health and well-being and
everything else yeah in a big way and I
really value what you do every August
August yeah it's awesome
no nothing no news notes you know
hardest would just avoid news I mean
forget phone I literally lock my phone
and it's safe but just to avoid coz
everywhere you go CNN is on everywhere
airports you go to a burger joint you go
go to the gym yeah I actually most of
the month I didn't even go to the gym
because TVs are on everywhere I did not
wear a really low hat and have to kind
of just stare down the entire time but
we're slammed with information
constantly that's the point yeah it is
and it's overwhelming and it's junk food
information most of it so that's it's
not it's not information information
yeah
well the same way that junk food is
what's responsible for our ever-growing
waste lines and you know the fact that
only you know eighty eight percent of us
are in are in good metabolic health or
because it's you know this this chronic
omnipresent exposure to junk food we are
getting you know information that is
essentially just junk food and obviously
there are exceptions to the rule people
like you what I try to do
without put out good quality information
for people but yeah I think social media
is a source of malaise for many people
and we're seeing record rates of anxiety
depression I mean in 2018 alone sales of
books related to how to improve symptoms
of anxiety shot up by 25% at one major
retailer alone so it's a big topic for
people and I think social media one
researcher in a study that I cite in the
book put it so eloquently the problem
with these with our devices is that they
reorient the gravitational pull they
have a really strong gravitational pull
of our attention so when they're around
it's like it's hard to focus on anything
but you know the phone or the social
media feed or what have you and it
stresses us out when we're not checking
our phones but then unlike a drug of
abuse so like when you are in withdrawal
for a given compound there is a
reduction in stress once you actually
get the compound whatever that drug
happens to be but the yeah the
difference with our with our smartphones
is that actually it increases the stress
yeah so we're stressed out when we're
not checking our phones and then when we
do check our phones it adds even more
stress into the equation and and so it's
a bit of a leap to connect you know
social media and smartphone use with the
chronic disease epidemic but I mean we
know the chronic stress is not good for
us it's an indiscriminate killer it
affects digestion in many ways in
negative ways it affects our immune
system negatively have they done many
studies I know there have been some just
about attention spans and ability to
think which sort of relates everything
back to dementia and Alzheimer's and
everything else because I noticed now
like one of the one of the real things
that I noticed is people never have just
the time to sit and kind of do nothing
you never you know it's like remember
the old days when we were in high school
and it was like if you're meeting your
friend on the corner you were like all
right I'll be there at 3:30 and 3:00
3:30 rolled around he wasn't there so
you don't have to stand there if you
would stand and wait where now we have
no kind of just stand and wait time or
sit in a waiting room a waiting room
you're supposed to wait in the waiting
room but
said you're working we're all guilty of
this right so I'm better than anyone but
like that that we don't give our brains
just like a rest really maybe when we're
sleeping but often the last thing we're
doing at night is this and the first
thing we're doing the morning this I
don't bring my phone in the bedroom yeah
at least most of the time and that I
found could be really positive actually
yeah I mean if you think about it just
as you were saying that it made me
realize that contemplation and
introspection have become like vestigial
organs yeah you know there's like
they've become like these obsolete
artifacts yeah of time past what because
it's almost like if you saw someone just
standing on a corner
you'd be like he's up to no good like
why would you just be standing on a
corner no what are you just standing
there it can't be nothing yeah it's a
problem I mean I I'm definitely I'm
gonna use social media a lot but even
you know I could see there are times
even when my own mental health when I
when I need to put the phone away and
take a break I get you know commenters
and a lot of it I mean often in the
comments that I get on my on my social
media feeds are are positive but then
you'll get some commenters that are
really negative somebody the other day
called me a literal cancer like a
literal cancer not just a metaphorical
cancer not a literal and that's it's
even a step up from Nazis yeah so yeah I
mean it could be it could be hard to
take but I think you know you have to
develop a thick skin and and and
building in to our schedule reprieves
from technology for me when I go to the
gym I'll lock my phone occasionally in
the in the locker or I'll do cardio and
it's just you know cardio is one of
those things where you can kind of you
can listen to your music but it becomes
a lot more difficult to to use your
phone you want to join me for off the
grid August I mean yeah you're down yeah
I think maybe what I'll do this year is
I'm gonna select like hands select like
10 or 20 public people and be like I
challenge you to join me don't sound
like let's see what happens if a whole
bunch of us check out like because I
suspect everyone will have a very
similar situation to me which is pretty
damn good
now just David do it as well or he
doesn't go off the grid because I'm
still have businesses to run yeah
there's also use your what he but he
does try to limit the checking like quit
in the morning make sure there's no
major fires and once at night but but
that's the limit of it and also we don't
really talk about news or any of that
kind of stuff
because it's like when you're in
something that the level that I'm in it
I feel like you do have to have that
that reprieve yeah I think it I'm
telling you I mean right now okay yeah
I'm definitely down for the challenge
yeah we'll see how I feel come yeah well
but I think this is gonna be one of the
major like I don't have all the all the
answers I think this is gonna be one of
the major challenges of of our
generation trying to figure out where
that balance lies between this this
embracing of Technology which I think
has done so much good for the world
obviously I mean I get to do what I do
thanks to technology but but it
definitely has led to challenges in the
way of mental health and do you think
it's it's on us meaning like us
old-timer
are you a gen Xer too or you consider
you're a Gen Y or oh excuse me but so
fruit but even for it for an old-timer
Gen Y I go that millennium or yeah or an
old-ass Gen X guy like me do you kind of
think it's on us to fix this because
it's like the baby boomers are slightly
aging out now and it's like we all
focused on the Millennials forever and
the Lannisters they're still super young
they're not right you know they have no
real power yet although they scream a
lot but like they have no real power and
that we the the Gen Y Gen X people were
the last ones to remember the world
before the phone you know II mean like
there was a time I didn't have a cell
phone in college you probably had one in
college right I had a cell phone yeah
all right
but that shows you it's like we're the
last ones to remember that and there's
something valuable in that knowledge oh
absolutely I mean the cell phone that I
had in college was a flip phone and it
emitted two colors that were you know it
was as bright as the dimmest bulb yeah
today our smartphones have been millions
of colors right in light up an entire
room so this is another topic that I
cover in the genius life is circadian
strum yeah circadian biology and how
disruptive that you know our smartphones
have been to that which is a whole other
area you know that we could talk about
yeah let's do that a little bit because
just the light that you talk well you
talk about it on the phone but also just
lights that
we're around all the time and yeah it
throws your sleep out of whack
artificial I'm watching TV right before
bed yeah we're just we're all living in
a constant state of jetlag due to
artificial lighting we're not getting
enough light early in the day which we
need to anchor our body circadian rhythm
which is the the timer basically that
dictates when we're gonna be at our most
energetic at our most coordinated at our
most focused when we're gonna have the
best digestion the best metabolisms to
partition and to utilize energy and also
when we're gonna get the most when we're
gonna begin to wind down for the evening
and get those rejuvenating and in
restorative aspects of sleep what's the
what's the phrase when they found this
with older people that like as dusk
comes around they usually that's where
you start seeing some memory stuff do
you know about this well there was a
concept of afternoon diabetes where your
metabolism you just you become less
insulin sensitive later in the day one
of the one of the mechanisms by which
that occurs is the hormone melatonin
become but it starts to be released by
the pineal gland and melatonin it's an
amazing hormone it's involved in this
process called autophagy which is sort
of like the connemara method that
biology uses to clean up our cells you
know to tidy up get rid of old worn-out
proteins and organelles and it's
involved in DNA repair which is amazing
it's one of the reasons that's been
proposed why you'll see an increased
risk of certain cancers and nightshift
workers which make ups like something
like 20% of the global workforce so yeah
I mean you tend to become less insulin
sensitive sensitivity and energy
metabolism that's it's really our
hormones are oriented in a way to to
support daylight associates associated
activity when the light is out when it's
light out mm-hmm
and we're just you know evolution has
anticipated that we're gonna be less
active at night as diurnal creatures and
so we become less insulin sensitivity at
night I'm not sure that the cognitive
link but there is certain you know we
tend to be more alert earlier in the day
than we are later in the day I mean that
makes that makes total sense yeah I know
there's no scientific anything to this
but one of the things that I noticed
with our dog Emma was that around five
o'clock or so when it
you know because we're just getting out
of the winter now that was so the Sun
would go down earlier and it seemed like
that was when she would be the most
Restless or the most sort of exhibiting
more signs of being in pain or something
I have no idea that has anything to do
with circadian rhythm or just maybe it
had something to do with later dinner I
don't know something but it just seemed
like you just start seeing odd things
you know yeah I mean our circadian
clocks dictate the way that our
neurotransmitters work the way they are
there are hormones work I mean cortisol
which is an energizing hormone is
highest in a day and it begins a long
gradual decline to the end of the day I
mean so there there is like aspects of
our of our cognitive function of how
energetic we feel are related to our
circadian rhythms there's no there's no
doubt about that
and so I talk about ways of anchoring
then that function one of the I think
most important things that a person can
do is make sure that you get bright
light in through your eyes first thing
in the morning or sometime before noon
there are these proteins in the eyes
called melanopsin proteins discovered by
one of the guys on the team section pand
a brilliant researcher at the Salk
Institute who I had the pleasure of
interviewing for my podcast and these
proteins are there fairly insensitive
but they respond to about a thousand Lux
of light or higher you can actually
download an app I believe it's actually
called Lux on your iPhone to get a sense
of your ambient light intensity and a
thousand Lux basically which you'll you
can easily get from standing by an open
window even on an overcast day flips a
switch on those proteins which then
activates a small region in the brain
called the suprachiasmatic nucleus sort
of the brain's master clock which then
sets off this 24-hour cascade of you
know hormone fluctuations and the like
throughout your body and so that's I
think the most important thing that you
can do you cannot food also acts like a
time setter so I think it's important to
be mindful of when we're eating you know
we're tent we I think where our bodies
are best at utilizing and partitioning
energy during the day so you know this
whole like intermittent fasting concept
that's been popularized
lately and by the media I think
intermittent fasting can be useful but I
think that the most the the greatest
health benefit that I've seen kind of
Orient's the the food consumption to
earlier in the day you know eating like
an hour or two after you wake up and
then stopping eating two to three to
four maybe hours before you go to sleep
that's been called early time restricted
feeding in the literature I think can be
super helpful independent of weight loss
seems to improve people's blood pressure
blood sugar and things like that alright
so for everybody that wants to live the
genius life and become extraordinary and
that is what it says on the title of the
book yeah what else should we be
thinking about in these last couple of
minutes like what else should people be
trying to do well the book is like a 360
degree lifestyle approach and every
topic that I cover in the book could
easily warned its own volume but I try
to I try to make things actionable
approachable and achievable for people
using only the most relevant science and
making it really you know digestible but
essentially moving the body I think is
crucially important I talk all about
exercise in the value of resistance
training we know that resistance
training you know building stronger
muscles it becomes increasingly
difficult to do as we get older but all
the more valuable it's one of the best
ways to actually improve your metabolic
health which we know that most people
are not in in an ideal metabolic health
being mindful of your circadian rhythm
as easy as it is to to anchor your
body's circadian rhythm first thing in
the morning it's one another one of the
central challenges of modern life has
become to maintain that sent that
circadian rhythm and so kind of guarding
your eyes from bright light in the
evening you know maybe I'm a big fan of
blue light blocking glasses yeah do you
do that iPhone setting like that yeah
setting yeah yeah and some of the yeah
super important there's a lot of
gimmicks in the health and wellness
world the biohacking space but amber
color glasses I think are are actually
pretty useful and yeah I talk all about
environmental toxins just be more just
being more sort of aware of what's in
the environment and and yeah knowledge
is power but if you're just gonna let
that knowledge sit on the bookshelf in
the back of your psyche
and gather dust then it's not going to
serve you I think you got to act on this
on this on that knowledge and yeah
there's no time like the present to
start good finish man thanks all right
people if you want to become
extraordinary go to genius life book.com
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlists they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell